I'm Laura Ingram this is the Ingram
angle from Los Angeles thanks for being
with us tonight
not having Gavin that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
never let a crisis go to waste that was
Rahm emanuel's classic line from the
Obama era and it still captures the
Democrat party's approach to politics
take California's greasy Gavin Newsom
who's trying to use a pair of mass
shootings in his state to build his Bona
fides going into 2024. nothing about
surprising everything about this is
infuriating the Second Amendment is
becoming a Suicide package
okay if that guys the Democrats post
Biden Plan B
they're in trouble
leaders take charge and when necessary
they take responsibility but what does
he do he takes low brow pot shots when
he wasn't blaming the Second Amendment
to the Constitution he was gaslighting
the first attacking the Free Press well
the one network that consistently holds
him accountable telling an ABC affiliate
in California that it's a disgrace what
we say at Fox every night he said
there's xenophobia there's racial
priming whatever that is what they've
done to perpetuate crime and violence in
this country what
xenophobia racial priming Newsome
immediately tried to tie the attacks to
right-wing Trump supporters and of
course other top Democrats did the same
Auntie gonzealot Chuck Schumer tweeted
about the need to stand up to bigotry
and hate and the odious Adam Schiff
claimed aapi bigotry was a possible
motive in the shootings
and with Newsom and the gang's reflexive
call for more gun control even CBS and
MSNBC had to admit that California
already has restricted gun laws in the
country
California has the strictest gun laws in
the U.S California is doing everything
that anybody who is looking for tough
gun restrictions to exist they're doing
it all right now
but Gavin was having none of that
with a bizarre Jack nicholson-like smile
and laugh effect he looked like he was
going for the Oscar
he claimed to care about your kids
we were just talking to number one
killer number one killer of our kids
last year was Guns the hell is wrong
with us I'm not saying take everybody's
guns and stop that the extreme back and
forth some damn Common Sense common
dignity kids being traumatized over and
over again because of these damn drills
at school for Shooters and we're not
dealing with the damn issue
what a creep now it turned out that a
deranged elderly Asian man with a
criminal history including unlawful
possession of a firearm was the gunman
in that horrific shooting that killed 11
on Sunday in Monterey Park doing during
a lunar New Year celebration
and that's where that Rampage in Half
Moon Bay that's about 30 miles South of
San Fran the suspect in custody is
another senior citizen a 66 year old
Asian man
now the people killed mostly worked on a
mushroom farm which local said was known
to be a marijuana growing Farm
the suspect was subject to a temporary
restraining order after a former
co-worker and roommate accused him of
attacking and threatening him back in
2013.
so there's no evidence that racial bias
was a motivating factor
but again facts don't matter
not when your goal is to score political
points
there's demagoguing instead
and then there's demagavin
where's the Republican Party been on gun
safety reform they blocked it every step
of the way one state can't do it alone
shame on them and shame on those that
allow and perpetuate
that to be rewarded politically
shame on them shame on these judges you
deserve better
we deserve better
ending the epidemic of gun violence
requires doing what Newsome refuses to
do
send an unequivocal message that there
will be no tolerance for Crime of any
kind in a state
but after Decades of liberal leadership
criminals here in California know how
easy it is to get away with illegal drug
sales car theft shoplifting vandalizing
of course larceny of any kind and we
know far worse
that has to end
this isn't that hard and the demonizing
of law enforcement stop supporting and
defending pro-criminal prosecutors who
are part of the problem
and the sanctuary City policies that
have empowered the cartels and the gangs
throughout the state
gun control doesn't stop criminals
hell-bent on committing crimes
just ask the people of Illinois
laying on the couch right here I heard
maybe anywhere between six to eight
shots uh looked sounded like it was
right up under the window it's Chicago I
don't think I'm surprised anymore when
it comes to like gunshots happening
anywhere it's not surprising me now
beyond the crime epidemic California has
huge problems a 25 billion dollar budget
shortfall the cities are unsafe
deteriorating from the needless coveted
lockdowns and as we know here in La
rampant homelessness
public schools are in Decline everyone's
trying to find a way out a pension
system that is in crisis and I mean big
crisis
so climate change Insanity rampant crime
high taxes running the state into the
ground all of it
but at least the Democrats can brag
about leading the nation with their
legalized weed industry
now even the LA Times had to admit a few
months ago we brought it to you at the
time that legal marijuana has also
spawned Outlaw growths and with them
violence shootouts robberies kidnappings
and occasionally as the times wrote
killings
muchas gracias Gavin
no wonder 300 000 residents are leaving
California every year for places like
Texas and Nevada
so despite his resounding reelection
newsom's in a bind
so what's the Escape for him
a run for the presidency of course
look closely you can see his wings
because Newsom is one of the Buzzard
circling President Biden for 2024. and
that means he's got to show his talons
you have one party that are
obstructionists you have a leader of
that party from the state of California
hasn't said a damn word about these Mass
atrocities unless there's a pattern
interrupt and we start calling people
out by name all those people on Fox
Prime Time really
crimes your number one issue you're not
going to deal with the leading cause of
crime which is guns
and you still think people should have
large capacity magazine clips and
weapons of damn War
what frauds absolute frauds
gaslighting a cable network instead of
his own shortcomings
that's going to keep people about as
safe as what Gavin's goons did by
chasing people off the beaches and out
of parks during coven that worked well
now Newsome may have a sharper mental
acuity than Biden but his policies are
just as demented
and the voters aren't having it and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else